it's Thursday so it's time for another
thankful Thursday I believe it's
important to think the people in your
life who have an impact on you and
helping your business grow because you
can't do this alone you need the people
around you to support you so today I
want to take the time to thank my sister
Stephanie now stephanie was one of the
first people who I brought on into my
business when I was first getting
launched and that's a really important
time you know when you're first
launching a business the people who you
surround yourself with our are super
critical because if they're just there
for the money if they don't really
believe in what's happening if they're a
negative energy for you then that could
be the end of your business that could
be it and on the other hand if you
surround some people who build you up
who give you ideas who bring positivity
who bring momentum and energy then that
can be that could be it too that could
that could be what helps take you out
and and stephanie was at she was always
a great supporter of everything I was
doing she was writing a lot of the
famous entrepreneur profiles that you
see featured up on my website even still
to this day and those stories not only
helped my audience and my website grow
but also helped me stay motivated and
you know seeing those entrepreneurs we
came from nothing and had so much
adversity in their lives and they
overcame it and kept going and built
these great companies help give me
motivation to keep going and so second
was a big part of that now stephanie is
still involved somewhat in the company
in terms of giving support and advice
and I recently relaunched my newsletter
and she wrote in something like Evan I
love me do with the newsletter I
actually read it now you know that
that's the kind of honesty you get from
your sister but anyway Stephanie I
appreciate everything you've done I love
you so much and I will have to find a
time to come and see you in New York
soon so that's my thankful thursday I
hope you guys watching will take the
time take five minutes today to give
somebody a phone call make a video right
somebody an email just to thank them for
the impact that they've had on you and
your business it'll make them feel great
it'll make you feel great and everybody
will have more energy to go out and
conquer the
they believe those you watching like the
video you can support me by clicking on
the link in the description you can
leave a comment let me know you think or
you can give a shout out to somebody in
the comments who you're thankful for and
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon